more now on the delta variant how it's
shaking up the pandemic response we're
joined by cbs news medical contributor
dr david agus who joins us from los
angeles doctor good morning
a million vaccinated in a million plus
in a day sounds pretty good
are we moving right now in the right or
wrong direction
well you know we have a new enemy i mean
so the data are changing and so
you know the only way we know how a
virus behaves is from real world
evidence
and what we're seeing now is that this
virus can spread like
crazy we're trying to counter vaccines
but we're not winning a hundred thousand
cases on friday
but anybody who says well the fact that
you can get a breakthrough means the
vaccines aren't working
is wrong 97 of current
hospitalizations are those who are
unvaccinated
so the vaccines are working remarkably
well in terms of preventing
serious illness and death which is
critical
talk to us about these new guidelines
masks mandates are back in
in flow in many cities and states who
is this directed at specifically
it's directed at you no it's directed
[Laughter]
what what we're seeing
is you know even people who are
vaccinated and when they're exposed to
the new delta variant
they can potentially spread the virus so
really whenever there are people
congregated together you need to wear a
mask
if you have young children at home
elderly or people with immune
suppression you
probably want to wear a mask around them
presently
we're in a new game and the new game is
the delta variant
and we have to change what we do the
science isn't changing the virus is
well dr rigg is do we know if
breakthrough cases can actually result
in long covid because we hear
about these breakthrough cases being
quote unquote mild
which is a range of severity from what i
understand
but is there enough data to actually
understand whether long covid
is a possible consequence of a
breakthrough case
it's a great question and one i get a
lot and right now it looks like if you
have
immunity from the two shots of pfizer
moderna or one of jnj
and you are exposed even if you're
mildly symptomatic
you will not get the associated long
covet symptoms
and we're not really seeing that and
there haven't been many reports of that
and that is good
news right you get a mild cold which
while we wish it didn't happen
there are going to be some breakthrough
symptoms but they're short
and they go away doctor can we just
clear one thing up because i think we've
seen some confusing headlines this week
one of them saying that vaccinated
americans
can pass along the virus just as easily
as unvaccinated
that's not true correct i mean if if you
get a breakthrough infection you can but
breakthrough infections
are so rare so are some of these
headlines confusing people
no question about it i mean make
declaratory statements out of context
and so what we're seeing in many of the
cases where there's a significant number
of people
exposed and people who are un vaccinated
you're going to spread it there people
who are vaccinated some may get mildly
symptomatic can they transmit to others
most probably really hasn't been shown
definitively but it's probably at a much
slower rate
than if you were unvaccinated i think
that's really important
the vaccines are working they are not
100 perfect as
no vaccine ever is but they're doing
what they need to do now and we as a
country have to step up
and continue the vaccination rates at a
much higher pace than we're doing now
or we're going to be in real trouble
over the next several weeks
okay dr agus thank you very much again
the vaccines work it just takes time
elaine thanks jeff